واشنطن تعلن مو عارضتها لاي عمليه عسكريه
تركيه جديده في سوريا وانقره تبحث اليوم
التوغل البريه المحتمل
في ايران ومحتاجون يضربون النار في مقر
البسيج في مدينه بندر عباس
الامريكيون فرنسيه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
افادت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون
ان الوزير لويد اوستن اجر اتصال هاتفيا مع
نظيره الترك
الامريكي بشان تصعيد العسكري في شمال
سوريا
في سوريا لهزيمه داعش وبحسب البنتاجون فقد
ابل نظيره التركي عن معارضه واشنطن القويه
لعمليه عسكريه جديده في سوريا
وفي باريس قال وزير الدفاع الفرنسي
سبستيان لوكورنو اتصال هاتفيا مع نظيره
الترك او في هذا الاتصال قال ان الضربات
التي نفذتها تركيا تؤدي الى تصعيد
التوترات وتهدد استقرار المنطقه والتقدم
الذي احرزه التحالف الدولي على مداع عده
سنوات في مكافحه 11 وكانت تركيا نفذت في
العشرين من نوفمبر الجاري سلسله ضربات في
شمال شرق سوريا على مواقع لمقاتلين اكراد
ويعقدوا مجلس الامن القومي تركي برئاسه
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان اليوم اجتماعا
لمناقشه مكافحه الارهاب والعمليات البريه
المحتمله في شمال سوريا الاجتماع الدوري
السادس والاخير هذا العام سيناقش ضربات
الجويه التي نفذتها تركيا ضد الموسلحين
الاكراد في شرق سوق سوريا وشمال العراق
كذلك سيتم اجراء تقييمات متعدده الابعاد
لعمليه بريه جديده في شمال سوريا ايضا
سيناقشه الاجتماع الوضع الاخير لعمليات
الجيش التركي في شمال العراق وستكون الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه على الجدول اعمال
الاجتماع
هند هند
حصل موقع ايران انترناشونال على نشره سريه
عدتها وكاله انباء فارس الايرانيه الرسميه
للقائد العام للحرس الثوري الايراني حسين
سلامي نقل فيها عن المرشد علي قوله ان
الاحتجاجات لن تنتهي قريبا واتم الكشف عن
هذه النشره السريه نتيجه اختراق مجموعه
الهاكرز بلاك
ريبورد وكاله انباء للحارس الدولي وقد
حصلت عليها ايران
جهاز المخابرات
على اجهزه المخابرات الغربيه قال ان الشعب
الايراني في حاله ثوره
[موسيقى]
هزار
في خطابنا القاه الرئيسه الفرنسي في
السفاره الفرنسيه بواشنطن اكاديمي والمكان
على قوه تحالف الفرنسي مع الولايات
المتحده وحضر مكان برنامج الولايات
المتحده للاستثمار او للاستثمارات
لمساعده الشركات المحليه يهدف بتفتيت او
يهدد عفوا بتفتيت الغرب وعلى هامش الزياره
وقع وزير الدفاع الامريكيه لوليد اوستن
ونظيره الفرنسي خلال اجتماعا اعلان نوايا
لتعزيز تعاون ثنائي يحترم التزامات
البلدين في مجال مكافحه الارهاب في جميع
انحاء العالم وقد نقش الوزيره
حلف شمال الاطلسي بيانيا
قال مسؤول في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
الفنتونال شحنه الصواريخ بيتش بيوت ربما
تصل الى اوكرانيا عن طريق دوله ثالثه لم
يسميها واضاف المسؤول الامريكيه ان بلاده
تبحث مع الحلفاء في النيتو نشر نظام
البيتريوت في اوكرانيا ما سيغير قواعد
اللعبه مع روسيا وفي وقت سابق من نوفمبر
الجاري طلب وزير الدفاع البولندي من
المانيا تسليمه اوكرانيا شحنه صواريخ
باتريوت ارض جو مخصصه في الاصل البولندا
وذلك لمساعدتك في الدفاع عن نفسها في
مواجهتها
اما المستشار الالمانيه فقال ان روسيا لم
تعد قادره على كسب الحرب في اوكرانيا في
ساحه المعركه مشيرا الى ان الهجمات
الروسيه على البنيه تحتيه الحيويه وانابيب
المياه والطاقه الاوكرانيه استراتيجيه
مروعه
في هذه الحرب في ساحه المعركه الهجمات على
البنيه التحتيه الحيويه وعلى انابيب
المياه والطاقه وعلى المدن والقرى
الاوكرانيه تمثل استراتيجيه الارض
المحروقه وهي مروعه ويائسه في الوقت نفسه
يجب على روسيا ان تفهم اننا سنواصل دعم
اوكرانيا
وانسانيا بسبب البنيه التحتيه المدمره
وبالاسلحه ايضا
نشره هنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الدفاع السعوديه توقعوا مذكره تفاهم مع
شركه اسبانيه لبناء عدد من السفن القتاليه
وتوطينها
اهلا بكم من جديد ضمن رؤيه السعوديه 2030
التي اطلقها ولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان وبحضور رعايه الامير خالد بن سلمان
وزير الدفاع ووزيره الصناعه وتجاره وسياحه
الاسبانيه ماريا رياسه ماروتو وقعت وزاره
الدفاع السعوديه والهيئه العامه للصناعات
العسكريه مذكره تفاهم مع شركه
نافانتي
وبناء عدد من السفن القتاليه متعدده
المهام لصالح القوه البحريه السعوديه
القوه البحريه السعوديه لتعزيز الامن
البحري في المنطقه وحمايه المصالح الحيويه
والاستراتيجيه للمملكه
وتتضمن الاتفاقيات توطين ما يصل الى 100%
من بناء السفن البحريه وصيانتها وتكامل
الانظمه القتاليه
وتركز مذاكره التفاهم على دمج انظمه
القتال في السفن الجديده وتصميم النظم
وهندستها وتطوير البرمجيات بالاضافه الى
الدعم اللوجستي وتصميمي برامج التدريب
الان مباشره نذهب الى هذه الصور الحياه
والمباشره من هواي حيث يوصل اكبر بركان
واسمه همم
اكبر بركان نشط في العالم يواصل ثورا
ههه
تعرضت طفله يمنيه في تعز لخطا طبي في احد
المستشفيات في المدينه افقدها حواس السمع
والبصر وادخلها في اعاقه دائمه
ادخلت المشفى بكامل حواسها لتلقي العلاج
لكنها عادت منه كفيفه لا تقوى على الرؤيه
ولا حتى الابتسامه او البكاء خطا طبي
ووضعها في اعاقه دائمه بين يدي والديها
بهذا الحال اذا اصبحت الطفله صدره بعد
سبعه اشهر من طاعتها جرعات علاجيه خاطئه
لا علاقه لها بالمرض الذي اسعفت من اجله
يقول والدها يعني
15 يوم
انا اتمنى ان الله واتمنى بس بنتي ترجع زي
ما كان اول الضحكه
هذا الملك مش حق بنتقاله ولا حق بنتي
وبعدين ما شفتوني الملف بعد ما ضربوه
للابره في قسم الاسعاف قتلته بالملف طوايل
الارض
قبل وقوعه لكن اهمال طبيب في المشفى تغلب
على ذلك لتصبح صدره واحده من بين اطفال
كثر قتلتهم تلك الاخطاء في مستشفيات تعز
هنا والده اخرى تفتش في اليوم الذكريات
بحرقه عنها ترى وجهها طفلتها التي ماتت
بنفس الخطا
تمام
جدا جدا
قتلت القوات الاسرائيليه شابين فلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
مواجهه حاميه شهادتها جلسه المساء
الاسبوعيه للحكومه البريطانيه في البرلمان
هي المنازله الاسبوعيه بينهما كالعاده
افتتحها زعيم وحزب العمال البريطاني
المعارض كرتونر بابتسامه يليها هجوم الحد
على سوناتا
اتهم الحكومه بانها تدفع الاموال للذين لا
يحتاجونها من المدارس الخاصه مرورا بشركات
النفط العملاقه وصولا الى الاعفاءات
الضريبيه التي في رايه متوفره للاغنياء
كما عرض على سوناك بتهمه
حزب العمال في مواجهه ما وصفهه بالتمرد
بين النواب حزب المحافظين على زعيمنهم
بشان
لكن يمكنني انا مساعدته في هذا الامر فهو
لا يحتاج الى صفقه قذره اخرى اذا اراد
مواجهه التعديل التي يطالب به النواب
المعادن للنمو او للناحيه تحقيق الهدف
الوطني
وبين صيحات الاستهجان والتاييد التي تنتقل
بين جهات البرلمان بحسب هويه المتكلم لم
تكن ردود سوناك اقل حده خصوصا لناحيه
اتهامه
بانه لا يصلح لقياده البلاد
ومستخدما سلاح استعمل عينه ورده على
اتهامه بالضعف قال سمعت ان استعمل اضعف من
ان يمنع بعض نوابه من المشاركه في
الاعتصامات التي تدعو اليها النقابات وصفا
الحزب العمال بانه يكرر الافكار القديمه
نفسها انها نفس افكار حزب العمال القديمه
المزيد من الديون المزيد من التضخم المزيد
من الاضرابات يقول ما يريده حزمه ان يسمع
فيما
القرارات الصعبه لهذا البلد
هناك رفض مطالبه عمال البريد وقطاع
التمريض بزياده الاجور بنسبه تفوق معدلات
التضخم قائلا انها غير معقوله ولا يمكن
تمويلها وفي موضوع عبور المهاجرين عبر
القناه اكد انه سيفعل كل ما يلزم للسيطره
على الحدود وحمايه السياده هي المواجهه
الاسبوعيه الحاميه كل اربعاء ياتي اليها
زعما الحكومه والمعارضه مجهزين بكافه
اسلحتهما ومصممين على الفوز بمعركه الراي
العام الذي ينتظر منهما كلام المقنعا
وحلولا لمشاكل البلاد فسناك واستمر
يستدلان اقتناعا بان نتائج الانتخابات
المقبله بعد عامين تصنع في جزء كبير منها
هنا تحت قبه هذا البرلمان العريق عبد الحق
العربيه
اعلن الملياردير الى الماسك الملك الجديد
لتويتر انه قدم جميع الابحاث لهيئه الغذاء
والدواء للحصول على موافقه زرع رقاقه
اللاسلكيه في دماغ الانسان وذكر ماسك في
بيان انه يتوقع ان تبدا تجارب زرع الرقاق
اللاسلكيه في الدنياغ الانسان في غضون سته
اشهر
انا اسطوره الروبوتات الذي نشرته في جميع
انحاء العالم اتم حتى الان نحو اربعه
ملايين عمليه توصيل طعام بنجاح
[موسيقى]
النشره الى العناوين
وعرضتها لاي عمليه عسكريه تركيه جديده في
سوريا
التظاهرات تتواصلوا في ايران ومحتاجون
يضربون النار في مقر للبسيج في مدينه بندر
عباس
خلال زياره مقالي امريكيون فرنسي
[موسيقى]